le ministre argentin de la santé inès
gonzalez garcia s'est fait piéger par un
journaliste réputé qui a révélé s'être
fait vacciner dans l'enceinte du
ministère par du personnel de l'hôpital
public de buenos aires le ministre
favorise est ainsi des amis et des
relations en visite officielle au
mexique le président argentin alberto
fernandez confirme la démission et il
déplore les faits personne ne peut
accepter dans les circonstances de
passer avant les autres pour la
vaccination
sauf que le nom du président qui à 61
ans est inclus dans la liste de 70
personnes dont certaines avec leur
famille qui ont reçu ce que les
argentins appelle des vaccins vip
anciens présidents ambassadeur
fonctionnaires avant le personnel de
santé et les plus de 80 ans
l'argentine compte plus de 2 millions de
cas de co vide et 51 mille décès pour 44
millions d'habitants depuis la fin
décembre elle a reçu plus d'un million
de doses du vaccin rue spoutnik v et
reçoit ces jours ci les premiers vaccins
chinois sinopharm deux ministres sont
tombés au pérou
la ministre de la santé pilar mazzetti
qu'on voit ici en train de dire qu'il
faut montrer l'exemple en attendant son
tour elle avait été secrètement vacciner
dès octobre dernier ainsi que 4 186
autres personnes haut placées avec le
vaccin chinois sinopharm qui était
encore à l'essai en phase iii au pérou
parmi elles la ministre des affaires
étrangères que le président péruvien a
mise à la porte également est imbibé
ception après avoir exprimé son
indignation et sa déception parmi les
487 l'ancien président du pérou martin
vizcarra qui s'excuse de n'avoir rien
dit aux péruviens pour ne pas nuire aux
tests en phase iii du vaccin mais il dit
qu'il n'a rien fait de mal
ceci a du mal à convaincre les péruviens
pour qui cet ancien président démis par
le congrès était le chevalier de la
lutte anti corruption
les gens sont encore une fois choqué par
le secret entourant ces vaccinations
on ne fait plus confiance aux
politiciens 17 hommes et on ne le fera
jamais plus de père ou tient ces
élections présidentielle et législatives
en avril et la corruption est au centre
de la campagne la pandémie qui a fait
plus de quarante trois mille morts pour
une population de 33 millions
d'habitants
le jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal